hello what's up with chief I'm still in
school and I've been meaning to ask what
are your thoughts on president in school
organizations possibilities of being a
president or a secretary and all that
stuff
does that really help in developing
leadership and got it I would say yes if
you want to be a leader the more you
practice leadership the better you'll
get so if you have a chance to be a
leader at school whether that's school
president whether that's the beat Club
leader whether that's a on a soccer team
or baseball team or music like whatever
your hobbies are whatever your passion
and interest are in life like you may
not want to run the whole school but
whatever your passions are to then bring
that into a leadership role where you
are responsible for other people the
faster you learn that skill the better
it is and to be able to do that while in
school like I would even try to hack it
more where I would not just try to take
the leadership position but try to get
guidance from either teachers who you
respect like if there's a teacher at
your school who you think is a really
great leader I would ask for his or her
perspective on what you're doing and if
not then even alumni of the school if
there's somebody who is a graduate from
your high school who is a great leader
that you respect to reach out to them
and say hey I'm I'm a student at your
school and I am leading I want to be
school president or I am the captain of
our soccer team or whatever I would love
to get your advice on this situation I'm
dealing with I don't think most people
get enough leadership skills early on in
life and then when you start a company
and you have to run a team you don't
know what you're doing like this is the
first time you've ever led or if you go
to get a corporate job and you go from
being just an employee to a manager you
don't get enough training on how to do
it so the faster you can get used to
leading a team in lower situations you
know like who cares if you're if you're
the captain of the local ping-pong team
and you don't give the best speeches
like who
it's not the end of the world it's the
super low risk but if you can start the
practice as soon as possible and build
the muscle up you're lifting weights
with with little tiny weights which is
great that's how you start you can't
walk into the gym and lift crazy heavy
weights and so the faster you start and
learn those skills the more it's gonna
serve you so I don't look at it as it's
going to be super impactful for
necessarily the team or this even the
school it's more for you like you will
learn the skills to get better so that
when you get older you can you've
already had years of experience I I was
voted the president of an international
association in the college in my college
unfortunately due to my citizenship as a
Filipino I got picked out of that so I
was a bit bummed out but like find other
leadership positions that you can take
like this is the best this will happen
again like you will be a leader of
something else and you might get kicked
out great
now you've learned how to deal with it
more important than what happened is how
you deal with it because you you had
this position you loved it
you got kicked out for maybe a stupid
reason but you still got kicked out
you'll face this situation many many
more times in your life how you deal
with it now will set you up for success
and how you deal with it in your future
so a lot of people what happen is they
got kicked out they lost their job and
then they feel sorry for themselves and
they never try chasing anything big
again they only do the safe thing the
only do the easy thing they stay doing
the same thing over and over and over
again and they end up hating their lives
where you have a chance now to say okay
I this one position I want to be a
leader so I'm gonna go and get a
different leadership position maybe not
at the same school maybe not the same
club like something else but I'm a
leader I want to work on my skills and
so what you're doing is teaching
yourself that when you lose you get back
up and you go again Yvonne what's that
man from Mexico thank you something hit
me how
find your path I mean you guys you seem
to know your thing from the very
beginning and you know sometimes I kind
of know what I like but I'm not quite
sure that I really love it because I see
the passion in your eyes or the passion
in Oprah's eyes or the passion in I
don't know
Elam mouska because you know what you
feel it but you don't know it you feel
it and that's a thing that doesn't
happen to me so I don't know how to do
that okay listen this is a great
question and one that a lot of people
are struggling with don't look at
anybody that you look up to now it's not
the right frame of reference from this
question because yes I know what I want
to do now but I didn't have it from the
beginning I didn't know what I wanted to
do from the beginning even Oprah Oprah
didn't know what she wanted to do from
the beginning she started off being a TV
host like doing news and stuff and she
didn't want to do that and when she did
her first talk show was an experiment
and this is the best thing like if you
love Oprah I would really go back and
look at Oprah's early story because I
felt the same way she went off and did
her first TV show where she was able to
host like doing what she's doing like
Oprah Winfrey Show and she said I got
off that show and I felt like I was
breathing for the first time and that's
what I felt too when I went and I did my
YMCA presentation entrepreneurs for
three people it made no practical sense
but I got off at feeling like this is
awesome like I need to go back and do it
again and so you know I was I was how
old was I then I was 22 or 23 when I did
that first speech what you have to do is
explore you say yes you try things
somebody invites you to somewhere you go
you say yes you say yes you say yes and
then you just see did you enjoy it it
doesn't have to be like your lifelong
thing yet just you date and you say yes
and you try it and you explore it and if
you enjoy it then you go back and do it
again but what's it doesn't matter if
you're oh dude how old are you 27 you're
you're you're young man you got tons of
time to figure stuff out but you're not
going to figure it out sitting on the
ouch like you get out by by saying yes
and trying you can spend the next three
years just trying a whole bunch of stuff
and still be young enough to go and
start your business people start their
businesses in their 60s and 70s and
still go out and have massive success
but here's the thing don't spend the
next 40 years just thinking about what
your passion is you have to get out and
try stuff and say yes and explore so
whatever dream you have whatever idea
whatever thing you want to try just find
the smallest way to try don't make it
some big impossible thing that you need
venture capital for and read a huge team
for find the smallest like you want to
try salsa dancing great go tonight well
you may be a nerdy how to salsa go
tonight to a salsa club and just and
just pick it up and learn right that's
it like you want to be a youtuber get
your phone out and record today right
find the smallest possible way to get
started and just start expect to suck
whatever you do you're gonna suck at it
really badly but it's more did you enjoy
the process like did you enjoy that
thing and you want to go back and do it
again okay thank you so much do it man
don't get caught up on the age you see
good good come back and tell me how much
you're winning I want to see it I got
your hand for prez what's up man
what's going on okay so um so I've been
doing this music thing for about eight
years now and I'm finally like at a
phase where I feel like I'm ready to put
myself out there and I've been doing
like the most shows I've ever done like
big crowds opening up for artists that
I'm listening to and it's like it's in
the right direction nice I just want to
know like when you um like have like a
vision that you worked on for so long
how do you keep the belief just like to
the strongest ability even during the
journey in the process like how do you
just keep that vision strong like what
are some things you tell yourself so I
try to surround myself with the people
who inspire me to keep going and achieve
greatness so you know like it's physical
environment like look you know I got on
my wall I got I got people that I look
up to I got my favorite entrepreneur I
got my parents I got Kanye on the back
of the wall they're like my youtube
channel I do it for myself I want to be
around people doing great things every
single day and so here's the thing
though like you're eight years in you're
starting to hate it this is where a lot
of people actually screw themselves over
they sabotage like now you've had a
little bit of in your taste a little
taste of success
now you might start to separate yourself
from your friends from your family from
your environment that you're used to the
comfort zone you might get a little bit
more hate or like oh look at what he's
doing is not one of us anymore
that's where a lot of people sabotage
themselves and then they bring
themselves back down where what I
encourage you to do is you got to you
got to switch up your environment where
like who's your favorite singer or who's
your favorite rapper who's your favorite
artist um I want to say like Tyler Kanye
um those kind of artists you're talking
about big dreamers man yeah like I said
like surround yourself with it like I
got Kanye on my wall right there man
he's on the far corner surround yourself
with it like if you if you played a
Kanye West interview every morning or a
clip from it or Tyler or whoever it is
Jake oh like whoever you look up to
it'll shift your mindset if you're
around Kanye even for five minutes a day
it'll shift your mindset here that
you're in you could do bigger things
like you've done it for eight years it's
awesome now you're just starting to hit
your stride listen you are already
what would Kanye say you were ready to
put yourself out there from day one why
did I have to wait eight years that now
you feel you're ready to put yourself
out there like go right and so shifting
that mindset where not that the people
in your life may be they may not be
hating on you that's fine but but like
the people are pushing forward to say
dude like you're capable of so much more
mm-hmm then surround yourself with that
because if you're around that every day
I'm we've done a bunch of singers
rappers on the channel so I'd be
consuming those top tens
those ants presses or if they have their
own channels like consume their stuff
even if their songs like if Kanye West
music hey you're my producer just joined
in and like we're just trying to really
push the album hearts yeah but you
listen it's not just about this album
dude it's about it's about it's the
forever it's the legacy it's the mindset
it's every day putting in eight more
years of work but like in your eight
years of work how hard were you actually
grinding for those eight
years like make it more important to
make it like nothing you slacked off but
you could have pushed harder if you just
believed in yourself more you'd be even
further ahead than you are right now so
whatever this album is is great but it's
just the beginning dude like your your
worth is not based off the success of
this album you'll do it you'll push it
it'll go as far as it came but it's more
like album 3 and album 10 and album 25
like you're a legend in the making and
so yeah this this is your first start
awesome but you got to keep putting in
the work and believing that you're gonna
be a huge star right believe it you will
be a dude yeah all my gang is in here
right now we're all listening to you
brothers I love it what's up gang listen
here's here's the thing I want to hear
your best track like DM me the link to
YouTube video or Spotify or whatever
like the track that you are most proud
of yeah I want to hear I want to listen
to your sound man and what I got I got
you okay good and then and then just do
that like if your first of all if you
got chops I'd be making a song a day
every single day I want to hear you sing
whether it's your own unique creation or
your you're doing a cover of a yay song
or something like everyday I want it I
want to hear you the quantity will lead
to the quality so get even better but I
want to see you out there daily I think
I think if you can if you can even even
low-key like get your phone and just go
right I don't know like did you
freestyle that you like you think you
think on your songs like what's your
style who I listen to like Kanye's like
say like that but but can you do go from
the dome or do you I mean like I mean I
write more so than I go from the dome
but I mean yeah my freestyle is this is
fire you know then then dude like I want
to see a daily video man like if you can
actually go from the dough in freestyle
that that takes you five minutes a day
make it make a five minute freestyle
everyday and pop that on your Spotify on
your YouTube SoundCloud just such a
process you know every day like you're
doing the same thing working and [ __ ]
I'm new I'm new to your channel my mom
action for
to you good I love your mom you should
be doing this outreach every single day
putting out fire like if you're doing
freestyles from the dome everyday and
you do a once a week cover of a favorite
of a famous like take Miley Cyrus and
make it your own right like do some
crazy cover in your own in your own
style you will get attention and people
will come to you you just got to you got
to not hide the stuff inside you got to
be putting out there everyday got you
great this is a start man do this if you
tell yourself a story long enough you
start to believe it won't you believe it
you act like it I am Tulsa what a wail
out of handcuffed lightning though
Thunder in jail now you know I'm bad
over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 250 for confidence or
every single day for 250 four days I
will be sending you a video between 30
seconds and 5 minutes long that you
start your morning with around making
you feel confident it's absolutely free
check out the link in the description
below to get access